red table talk returned on thursday for
their season 5 premiere and no the much
talked about will smith slap was not
addressed instead a title card appeared
at the beginning of the episode
addressing will's behavior reading
considering all that has happened in the
last few weeks the smith family has been
focused on deep healing some of the
discoveries around our healing will be
shared at the table when the time calls
until then the table will continue
offering itself to powerful inspiring
and healing testimonies like that of our
incredibly impressive first guest that
incredibly impressive first guest global
superstar janelle monae who used the
platform to reveal publicly that she is
non-binary after previously coming out
as pansexual in 2018. i'm non-binary
yeah so i just don't see myself as a
woman or
solely or right you know i feel all of
my energy i feel like god is so much
bigger than
the he or
but i will always always stand with
women yeah i will always stand with
black women but i just see everything
that i am yeah beyonce beautiful beyond
the binary when i see people i see your
energy yes i don't see like how you
identify it totally and i feel like that
opens you up to fall in love
i love the fact that she brought that up
and she's there was a quote to like the
fact that she says you know you need to
figure out your truth in your journey
before you come out publicly and that's
why people were saying well you said you
were pansexual why you know about you've
got to find your journey and that's what
she's going through and now she's able
to talk about it publicly i think
there's something interesting that
janelle says there when
when they say that they see your aura
and your energy
first yeah yeah uh rather than
something that you're identified by
and
you know
in these years of us talking about um
people speaking their truth and being
their truth and living out who they feel
that they are i think for a lot of
people that's kind of just what they're
asking for yeah like see me the way that
my energy is and the way that i want to
be seen and someone like janelle
um
taking her platform and saying this is
the way that i am here right and this is
the way that i would love for people to
be or not not love for people to be for
love for people just to you know see me
the way that i see me yeah um i do want
to read that book i do too
yeah yeah and you know i think it was
january 2020
she tweeted out just the hashtag i am
non-binary and people are like you
already talked about it that was just
supporting the community not actually
speaking about herself so just if people
are confused about that was actually the
first time she actually actually
acknowledged it on red tabletop and so
they're clarifying it yeah correct i
want to know what your thoughts on
because uh the fact that they did not
talk about will smith and the whole
slapping at the oscars and just put that
statement out do you think it was the
right thing to do uh
ah
i know
well for
publicity purposes let's say like
drumming things up they they can sit on
that
they can sit up they can sit on that and
and wait
um
maybe till a time where it's not as
fresh
uh for lack of a better word yeah the
time where it's not as fresh um
to
talk about and i'm wondering if it's
because they want to get particular
players involved at the table to
actually talk about it together
i just you know i just i was waiting i
think a lot of people were waiting that
this is gonna all break down on the red
table talk that she was gonna
acknowledge it and that's what the show
is about is to actually talk about your
emotions and talk about your own
experiences so i'm really surprised it
didn't bring it up
i was really expecting her first episode
to acknowledge her own experiences well
a certain segment of the population have
been putting a lot of heat on jada for
what had happened that evening
and um she knows how to handle that sort
of thing but she knows how to handle
that sort of heat i think this is part
of it is picking the right time
so that it becomes
so that they can have more of a control
i think over what the conversation is as
opposed to having the raw emotion of
what people have been kind of spewing
out over the last few weeks you know
it's it is
that emotion i think is waning a bit
now they should have talked about it
they think they should have gone right
into it that's what you were that's what
you would have done
just talk about it i was waiting okay